On September 16, 1890, a man boarded a train
in Dijon, France, waved goodbye to his brother,
and headed for Paris.
He was carrying one of the greatest inventions
of the age – the world’s first motion
picture camera technology… two years before
it was developed by anyone else.
In fact, our man was on his way to New York
to complete his patent and unveil his discovery
to the world.
But when the train pulled into the station
in Paris, the man was nowhere to be found.
He – and his invention – had disappeared
without a trace.
[Intro Music Plays]
Louis Le Prince was an artist and inventor,
a painter and a photographer, who entered
the arms race to create the first movie camera
in the 1880s.
His initial attempt, completed in 1886, was
a camera with 16 different lenses arranged
in a grid pattern that would each capture
a sequential frame of film.
The problem was that each lens took its photo
from a slightly different angle.
When played back, the resulting movie looked
odd and disjointed.
Like any good scientist or artist, Le Prince
went right back to work, revising and refining
his technology.
In 1887, he created a much simpler camera
that used a single lens and took photographs
onto small glass plates.
But Le Prince wasn’t satisfied.
In order to both capture and project the
images fast enough to achieve the illusion
of motion, he needed a material that was strong
but still flexible, heat-resistant, and transparent.
He experimented with systems that used glass
plates, and paper-backed film strips, none
of which worked very smoothly.
Then, in 1889, while visiting his brother
in France, he got his hands on a new medium
that would soon revolutionize the world of
photography – the flexible, emulsion-coated
material known as celluloid.
Seeing its potential, Le Prince immediately
began cutting it into strips and reworking
his camera and projector to take advantage
of this new medium.
And it worked.
The world had its first dedicated movie camera
and projector!
HUZZAH!
Punches Eagle!!!
Le Prince contacted his wife, told her to
set up an event back in New York to unveil
his invention, and initiate new patent proceedings.
Then he hopped on the train bound for Paris.
And just like that – he disappeared.
So what happened to the man who invented the
first motion picture camera?
No one knows.
His body was never found.
Some have suggested that he committed suicide,
and threw himself from the train.
Others wonder if his brother might’ve killed
him, though no motive leapt to mind.
Another other theory – one advanced by Le
Prince’s family at the time of his disappearance
– pointed the finger at competing inventors.
Less than a year later in 1891, Thomas Edison
applied for his first motion picture patents.
By 1894, he’d opened his first kinetograph
parlors in New York.
And in December 1895, the Lumiere Brothers
held the world’s first commercial movie
projection in Paris.
So, if Le Prince actually made the first movie
camera and filed for the patent, why is the
invention credited to Edison?
Under American law at the time, a person was
not considered dead until seven years after
their disappearance.
So, during those years, it was hard for the
Le Prince family to legally pursue or protect
Louis’ patents.
Though they tried.
The Le Prince family joined a lawsuit against
Edison soon after his disappearance.
Their star witness was Le Prince’s son and
assistant Adolphe.
But despite his best efforts, the trial ended in 1901 with a ruling for Edison.
That same year, a distraught Adolphe died of a gunshot wound while duck hunting
on Fire Island, New York.
Whether it was a suicide or an accident we may never know...
Whatever really happened, Le Prince’s reputation
– and his contributions to cinema – have
survived... he didn't though... might have been better if he survived.
If I were him I'd prefer to have survived, myself.
His camera and projector design concepts,
as well as his use of celluloid film, are
strikingly similar to the technologies that
Edison, W.K.L.
Dickson, and the Lumiere Brothers would come
to in the following years.
Even though he may not get enough credit,
there’s no doubt that Louis Le Prince got
there first.
And today, many film historians consider him
the “father of cinematography.” Other than Wheezywaiter, of course.
Not to mention the subject of one of the great
unsolved mysteries of film history!
As well as the subject of the great animated Crash Course video you just watched.